all right there is a ton I have to talk
to you guys about this week as you
probably know I was in Israel last week
where I was invited to speak at a video
conference the remainder of the week was
spent wandering the streets talking to
people about peace and eating ridiculous
amounts of hummus spending most of my
time in Tel Aviv
I saw people of pretty much every race
color religion ethnicity and nationality
living side by side I heard Hebrew
Arabic English French Spanish Japanese
German and several other languages being
spoken simultaneously in restaurants in
cafes
I saw a coexistence in a part of the
world that has very little of it I also
spent a day in Jerusalem if you saw the
video that we posted a couple days ago I
tried to show how close these religious
sites are and give a little context to
an extremely small yet complex city
walking through the Old City of
Jerusalem I explored the Jewish and
Christian quarters and stop for falafel
in the Arab quarter I felt it was
important not just to talk about these
places as we do but actually to live
them as well I exited the old city at
the Damascus Gate where literally a day
before a Jew had been stabbed while
there was no doubt the neighborhood was
tense there was also a feeling that this
was life and life goes on unfortunately
I heard about the San Bernardino
terrorist attacks while on the beach in
Israel I can't really explain to you
guys how incredibly surreal it was to be
so far away from something so horrific
happening 60 miles away from where I
live
while I was 7600 miles away from home
adding to the surreal feeling was that I
was in the epicenter of a country that
deals with terrorism in some form or
another pretty much every day
suddenly I had people asking me what it
was like to be in America with all our
mass shootings the world felt completely
flipped on its head on the 14 hour plane
ride back to Los Angeles I read what's
left by my guest this week Nick Cohen
Nick is a writer for Time Spectator the
observer and standpoint his first book
what's left is an absolute must-read if
you dig what we do here though what's
left was written in 2007 Nick absolutely
nails so much of the lunacy we've been
talking about on the Left these days
from their dishonest tactics of lying
about opponents views to aligning
themselves with
who had just as easily have them killed
he goes on a journey through history to
show how the far left has so often
strengthened the very ideas that they
purport to be against there were so many
passages of the book that I felt like
could have been written today that it
was almost like reading signing from the
future he nailed the regressive left
before the term was even out there
speaking of the regressives you didn't
think I was going to get through a show
without mentioning them did ya yeah not
going to happen one of the issues I've
called them out on consistently is that
if they don't stop smearing the Liberals
willing to talk about Islamic extremism
that they're going to hand our future to
the far right we're seeing this right
this very second across Europe as
far-right parties or winning elections
and gaining in the polls from France to
Belgium to Sweden and more this is
clearly coming to the American shores
right now - as Donald Trump just this
week called for denying Muslims entry
into the United States obviously this is
idiotic over the top and ridiculous
but it can only exist in a climate where
fear of real discussion has been stifled
if we aren't afraid of talking about
Islamism especially the difference
between people and doctrine then we can
finally have an honest conversation
about refugees immigration and
everything else but if we do as the
regressives are doing this very second
by making no distinction between people
who are trying to talk about serious
issues versus people who trade on fear
then we help the real xenophobes and
silenced the Reformers even as a kid I
always loved john f kennedy's famous
quote we have nothing to fear but fear
itself its lofty and big but it hits
something that is extremely human
sometimes fear in things is scarier than
the actual thing itself that's not to
say that radical Islam isn't scary but
we also feed that fear if we don't deal
with it honestly now though we live in a
time when people are incredibly fearful
and much of it is with good reason as
we've seen the spread of an evil
ideology with no signs of letting up
that doesn't mean we have to be afraid
to speak out against it or silence those
who dare to do so actually of course it
means the exact opposite fear is what
they're aggressive and the far-right are
both going to use to splinter us against
each other so they can gain power
the world is in a strange fearful moment
right this very second we can either
give in to our worst impulses or try to
be better I'm pretty sure you guys know
which side I'm gonna choose as we sat in
a packed restaurant in Tel Aviv I asked
a friend how he feels about all the
stabbings without missing a beat he said
we have to keep living we have no choice
I think we could all use a little of
that spirit right now let's not give in
to fear fed to us by terrorists or fear
fed to us by politicians let's keep
fighting because if we don't choice is
exactly what we're going to give up my
guest this week is a writer for The
Observer The Spectator time and
standpoint he's authored two books you
can't read this book and what's left I
just read what's left and I'm thrilled
to have him here Nick Cohen welcome to
the show my pleasure
so Nick I was telling you right before
we started I just read the book so all
of your thoughts in what's left are
they're right at the tip of my brain
right now and I loved it I have been so
in this regressive left thing this far
left that your hope that your whole book
is about and you saw it you saw it early
so I want to get to that but before we
start give me some of your liberal
credentials because I want people to
know that you're a lefty what because
we're gonna you know we're gonna talk
[ __ ] about the left so I want people to
know you're an actual lefty yeah okay um
well I'm from in Britain in Europe you
wouldn't call me a liberal you'd call me
a socialist and from the Socialist Left
we for whatever its problems and they
are manifesto manifold and presumably
covered at great length in America used
to believe in things like separatism in
antique last item in feminism to an
extent in being a part of the party of
progress and used to have some idea
what's do the world and I gradually
realized looking around me but this was
no longer Kate's as you like if you want
to put it in sort of really young
Royall rhys-jones really dirt yeah I
didn't leave left less that's me that's
not really true but there was no longer
a universal left-wing message which
meant that people around the world could
say that we're oppressed and were
oppressed by hideously actually forces
left-wing resources so it being in the
UK I've had a bunch of my guests have
been lefties in the UK that are that are
talking about the same issues that
you're talking about what is going on in
the UK that I think woke you guys up to
this before it was awoken in America
because really here it's only in the
last year I think that that liberals are
waking up to what's going on on our side
yeah we've got a saying over here Dave
but Sir what whatever happens in America
happens in Britain in Europe five years
later I think who wants to see other way
around I think that really big arguments
and big battles we've had in Britain in
particular are now coming to America you
know there are the causalities been
reversed a bit um there's been the most
ferocious rounds here which I'm pleased
about because like you know I'm
polemicist on it was bland Amal I don't
believe it they're being PC and nice and
kind and gentle is a way of sorting out
problems is often a way of covering them
up but there have been huge rounds in
Britain really since 9/11 in my case
since II Rockwater Mouse might seem real
wrong but your older viewers may
remember your fatty decrepit viewers may
remember that once said under saying was
ennemy is 'le left-wing is used to
campaign in favor of rights for the
Kurds and Paul said under Saddam Hussein
fascist so in my case it wasn't 9/11 it
was 2003 with the Iraq war and I said
I'm thinking well we know what happened
to all that's my youth why are why are
you European left is full reason you
know you never need a good reason to the
plenty good reasons for post your
cleverly books
amber and one
eh why why was it there was simply no
concern for Kurds in Iraq for socialists
in the rifle trade unions in Iraq who
had been until the late eighties um will
be demos to bound them they'll be
petitions to their support they
understand my parents home all that kind
of thing and yes what what happened
there and once you start asking that
question it's very simple question who
your friends who to use old left and
land join your comrades who are you
sticking up for whatever kind of
critical you want to be of American
policy or British policy and our peace
again or visit for outs interview there
are always good grounds because of
American British policy but who are you
actually supporting and then you get
some rather ugly answers and you you
find a sort of great vacuum on almost of
the list so many good left wingers but
most left where a principled ideology
ought to be yeah
so you right there I mean you hit a lot
of the book so a lot of the book deals
directly with Iraq and how it woke you
up as you just said in the horrible
things that Saddam was doing and the
horrible things that the bath party was
up to so before we get into that because
I was actually surprised how much of
your journey was through Iraq but before
we get that specifically the phrase
regressive left so it was coined by
Maajid Nawaz and it's really it's really
taken off here and I'm beginning at the
beginning of the book you mentioned that
you didn't necessarily have a word for
this and you said you didn't want to get
too hung up sort of on words do you like
the phrase regressive left is ultimate
day but yeah but but there's something
else here's the thing what's left came
out in 2007 and my god and I lost jobs
because of it all hell broke loose and I
published it but the reason I didn't I
know I love the phrase aggressive lesson
it's absolutely right
the reason why I didn't put a name to it
is this you can say very easy oh this is
just the far left uh people who used to
be Marxist Leninist Trotskyist Stalin's
well
have you but here's the problem when you
interrogate these attitudes they go way
way way into the mainstream people don't
consider themselves less than assault I
mean typically in prison time sources
through in America as well from what
I've seen it's people in broadcasting
it's people in universities it's people
in schools it's people in publishing
it's people who are knows you have to
define themselves with quite variable
but then have a load of ideas around it
back in John Donne the terrible idea is
we've started on the far left and and
this is what grows people wild in
Britain when this book was published
because I wasn't just talking about some
people on the fringe all sorts of talk
about people I mean here in Britain will
say BBC side people right who never
consider himself extreme all will
consume himself moderates a neutral
unlike the simple look these ideas that
began on on the far left that it's okay
to go along with regimes and movements
that want to subjugate all winning kill
all homosexuals kill will Jews kill any
Muslim who of his or her own free will
decides to change their religion law
yeah society is no God there is no Allah
at all you're going along with all of
this it wouldn't matter if it was guess
see extreme what matters is this is
permeating the whole liberal spectrum
and that's what growth people wild
available yes
so we to me that was so obviously true
and it seems to be true about American
lens as well
yeah so you hit on a lot there so partly
it seems to me that it's a little bit
like the phrase you know the road the
road to hell is paved with good
intentions
that these people and I think you hit on
this a bunch that these people they they
have good intentions in that they don't
want extra war and we have had a
ridiculous both of our countries right
you in the UK immune America
we're only with you right we have had
plenty of ridiculous unnecessary Wars
we've done all kinds of things drone
strikes all of these things that we on
the Left are not thrilled with
but you make a really good argument for
what is the alternative that we
basically just give up on all of these
people that live under these horrible
theocracies and that's what put these
people in the far left in bed with some
really terrible people
yeah it's also Dave yeah all all if you
get a time machine go into the future
say 50 years into the future if they are
bound to be all kinds of ideas that are
accepting the objects on the fringes of
American society at the moment don't you
all your great pange on drugs in the
media
Time magazine New York Times barely even
think about will be the common sense of
their age that applies to bad ideas as
well as good ideas a really bad idea
started on the far left I would even say
it wasn't even left-wing at all after
the collapse of communism after the end
of socialism remember socialism defines
what it means to be a left winger for a
good hundred years you know some the
1880s through the nineteen eighties then
that all goes then suddenly there are
all these people
I mean Noam Chomsky is a classic example
to me who have that same spirit that no
longer have an ideology they can believe
in and so what do they do they start
just send will anyone who is against the
West can't be all bad
anyone who's against the West it has to
be the West's fault
we are the root cause to user a phrase
that's been repeated to death and then
you suddenly find people who call
themselves new radicals or progressives
or socialists or even feminists in going
along with movements we shot
anti-progressive anti-socialist
anti-radical anti women anti-gay
anti-semitic anti-everything
anti-liberal
in the classics of actually movement
sort of stepped out of a liberal
nightmare if you look at their effects
but because they're anti West that's all
what matters is because there's no
longer a positive program being
left-wing they just seized on anybody
who is against America against to you
Sarah
Robert contentious than you have noggins
birth we want later against
and that that just starts on the
extremes like good ideas start on
fringes and it it comes into the main
screen now that's not wholly the fault
immensely liberals you know never let
you up so many books off that'll never
lets our leaders off the hook
yeah passing is a perfectly possible
reaction the results are terrible and
not just in you know poor countries what
about people in America what about um
our people in Britain what about people
in my country Muslim women are now being
told well you gotta go through a course
well he's a free women in a free country
no second-class citizen so you don't
have to have a some some theocratic
legal system saying reference worth half
lesser man right whatever you but
somehow with you as a white guy say that
then people go bananas and you're
pushing your views on them yeah even
though if you're you're the one that's
abiding the laws of your country which
is what they're governed by well now I'm
afraid you'll also my country is
slightly worse than that in that you
know there's a danger we're not quite
there yet
we'll have parallel legal systems yeah
we'll have a system that in civil cases
divorce cases which you know big deals a
Muslim woman will the law seems quite
contentment sake we can settle this in a
Sharia Court but this is this kind of
racist is it not if you say to a white
woman you have to go to the court what
by residents worth half that a man you
know right all liberal opinion across
Britain across America across the world
will go wild
this is sexism misogyny this is
patriarchy but it's okay when it happens
to a brown skinned woman you know what
you in the name of liberalism we are we
are creating the classic double
standards of pre liberal days and you
know white people have more rights than
white people have more ice and brown
skin yeah so this is not just an issue
for how people are treated in Saudi
Arabia or Iran or any other country with
a
also we actually I would say and fear
classic legal system it's here now and
our society's yeah it does seem to be
that liberals ought to decide what type
of liberalism they believe in do they
believe in liberalism means we've all
evil rights we can universal values or
does liberalism mean well there's one
law for one group and one law for
another group depending on their coach
does part of this seem to you that it's
just the end game this is the end result
of identity politics we're going through
right now in America this really strong
phase with identity politics tell me
everybody here we're right so we're all
divided on on sexuality and race and
just every anything that you can divide
people on were divided on it right now
and is part of this just that you saw
the end game of all of this sort of
before we did
I don't think me a prophet sign actually
believes prophets or gods or Bibles or
carranza or tabloids or any of that so
yeah um to me there there is a big big
vacuum opened up at the end of the
twentieth century we're first of all as
I said before it may not mean so much to
you in America how big in Europe and a
lot of the world the collapse of
socialism to collapse in the belief of
of the planned economy of nationalized
society but also the collapse of a kind
of not collapse but a marginalizing of
liberal optimism little optimism just
says that look the universal human
rights doesn't matter what your skin
color is you know it doesn't matter what
your religion is you can't on say oh
it's my culture to oppress women you
can't say ignored laugh at you right
actually no they don't laugh of you and
that allows identity politics which
sounds fun
which sounds fun you know I've got a lot
yeah I read these reports of black
students at Yale and you think about
history of black oppression in America
and you can understand them less it it's
kids they go a bit nuts but identity
politics had
you think well you know okay let them
have their their fuss by density
politics has a hugely dark side because
you have no answer when the people who
say we are the masters of your identity
we are community leaders we are the
mullahs we're a rabbis we are the
priests we control this group this block
and we say you're part of our group our
block our community and we we say that
you don't have the same rights as a a
white anglo-saxon woman at Yale we say
you know the Constitution the Bill of
Rights doesn't apply to you it is
against your culture and that hasn't
been fought through at all right so we
split people into into these little
boxes but then what we end up carrying
the least about is the people that are
in the smaller boxes within those boxes
well as as marking the world Society
mentioned it
Margie's has this one honorable phrase
what about minorities within minorities
you know what about what about liberals
and dissidents of free thinkers the
blasphemers the women the gays the
people who say what the hell well hell I
am NOT this group I'm not a Muslim or
igloo or whatever I'm American
right and that to me is the the ultimate
irony here is that the spectrum of
people that I've brought on the show and
that now I've connected with on on
Twitter or wherever it is is I'm not
judging any of these people
based on their color or their religion
or their ethnicity I'm basing it on
their ideas which we are which is the
most liberal idea yeah well uh you
actually treat them as individuals which
is a very variable okay yeah uh god help
you ah the other problem of identity
politics is this is when you stop
treating people as individuals you kind
of identity politics is is is is a is is
it is a slippery treacherous conjunction
is you cannot have identity or you can
have politics politics means you don't
just look at people and say there's a
block in this instance what we talked
about
do Muslims what do you mean there's a
group cool
Muslims because when you say that you
normally end up handing over the right
to speak to these Muslims without asking
admission to the most reactionary people
in it the people who who want to enforce
a communal identity and want to enforce
it first of all yeah I know there's all
this paranoia going around after the
Paris attacks and those awful events in
California but it first and foremost
want to enforce it on their own kind on
their tribe in falsetto boos on them to
keep them down and the worst of it is I
think it's been particularly bad in
Britain in America because we have this
identity politics multicultural problem
that you've had is well you know what
about the men the women who say on a
second this guy who says a community
leader doesn't represent me I've never
voted for it I don't agree with him what
about this man who says he's a priest a
rabbi and mullah yeah I didn't believe
in all this crap or any partially
believe in it I believe in bits of it
but you you then start treating me as if
this guy owns me all is this group owns
me without my permission that that is
that is the huge weakness to date it's
well an awful lot before we go on to
great questions on you with a sound of
your rate with Assyria you know what
we're going to do about Islamic state
it's where everyday cruelty happens in
our society it's where men and women who
need a confident liberalism a liberalism
that believes in human rights a
liberalism that says well actually the
we're not going to say that what matters
first and foremost about you is your
color or your creed they need him to
help them and they turn around to the
very people who all to be able to help
them and they're not there in fact
they're on the other side in fact
they're on the other side that's that's
the key piece because it's not just that
it's there they're actually working to
stop the Reformers and by calling
everyone racist and all this stuff
and then you know what we have going on
very much so in America right now is
that Donald Trump just this week says
we're going to close the borders to all
Muslims well now he throws red meat to
the
right he gets he probably does more good
work for Isis recruiting that he could
possibly do but unfortunately he's been
strengthened by by a week left you talk
a lot about that actually about how they
though this far left group now what
we're calling the regressive
ultimately end up strengthening a lot of
ideas that they should be against yeah
overseeing with Trump and vice versa
yeah and vice versa I mean I was a
meeting today at the Guardian which is
where I work and I love the place and we
know he's his Britain's leading Lessing
newspaper and people in the audience
their first questions about Donald Trump
you know their first questions were you
know and you could see I'm perhaps I'm
reading too much into into the audience
members watch but Donald Trump was
stopping her she taking on reactionaries
in you know or on his own isn't beside
so you know you've got you it's very
hard to to get the notion that there are
two extreme rights there is the white
extreme right and I wouldn't until a few
weeks ago said Donald Trump as only him
he seems to be heading that right now
yeah yeah um and there is the lidless
extreme right dismiss extreme right and
you need to fight them both for the same
reasons and with the same arguments it
is very different people seem to find
that very very difficult to do it
strikes me is the only principled
position but I imagine when I walked
onto any campus in America and said that
I'll be no platform not only would there
be no platform but they'd be trigger
warned you they go into a safe space all
the other stuff we're talking about and
then you know it really is all so
frightening day yeah right I've had
several guests that I didn't think we're
that frightening that for some reason
have to have trigger warnings issued
before they they speak on campuses so
look a lot of this is happening in
Europe first which is another reason
that I'm talking about it so much
because I don't want it to take hold
here the way it has taken hold in Europe
what do you make of the far-right
parties that are now winning across
Europe right marine lepen
just one in France weird I now see that
in Denmark and Sweden
far-right
are leading in polls for the first time
ever Belgium so this thing seems to be
metastasizing right in front of our eyes
yeah I mean there are there are other
reasons for that day I mean the European
Union it's not like the USA
you know it's trying to be like the USA
without the common culture the common
institutions and as I'm fond of pointing
out to people new want to be like the US
I said well USA had one hell of a civil
war before it became in the USA today
anyway do you want do you wonder there
are other reasons but there's two things
I want to say one you might quite like
the earlier maybe lesson I think you
might quite like is is I seem to agree
on this is this you can't run around
treating your head or yeah having
trigger warnings and safe spaces when
I'd know celebrity or a politician make
society off-color remark about
homosexuals or women most likely sexist
mark about women and have it leading the
news and colonies on you know of times
and music needing accusing a culture to
calm themselves down afterwards and then
and then ignore religious homophobia
including bed early religious homophobia
among ethnic minorities you just can't
do that without paying a price because
don't think people aren't watching you
you know don't think the rest of society
lots of political rising on the left as
well as the right it's like it's a
private club you know they get stuck
themselves they're here the right walks
is Fox News and less walks is John
Stewart you know they just talk to
themselves
it's like a private club and everyone
understands the rules and they forget
this outsiders are watching us get
Outsiders are saying
you bloody hypocrites yeah you know you
you will you will have one rule for
white people and another rule for the
rest and you will not stand up to get
back a universal principle so there is
that that doesn't matter
political correctness in Britain has
become has become this kind of swear
word and it doesn't mean stuff that you
would understand
I believe Verona means deep deep deep
hypocrisy miss governmental government
so that's all true you can blame Leffler
on your hands you know beautiful but how
badly my love swear on your progress
where away bring it let's go he blew
vote for donald trump there has come a
point you just say will [ __ ] off
yeah right you're voting for Donald
Trump you're voting green lahpet we will
shine
we will not you know we will not give up
on you with your fellow citizens but
there comes a point where if you sell
tell with you you know you are opponents
the difficulty is and is it is come
identity American viewers know about
this we've now got the worst type of
leftist leading our opposition party
Labour Party who's like yeah a
caricature if I had to write an example
of what the worst of left is in Britain
Jeremy Corbyn girl me guy Kulkarni oh
yeah the only good thing about them
becoming Labour leader is books I roads
are now selling yeah but I mean by
selfish point of view a sign
yeah you know is is you've got the
terrible right in America I was trumped
in France with National Front in Sweden
and Denmark and all these places Poland
and Hungary popping up all over Europe
not just because of the Great America
like salon part because the European -
Tim currency has been one of the great
economic mistakes and and then you've
got a left in a space where a principle
that should be certainly in Britain
you've got this kind of yoga figure that
will go along with an any organization
however
fascistic as long as it's anti wet so
you know lots of people are feeling a
bit political politically homeless over
here yeah does it all feel like a
perfect storm to you what's going on
right now and again this is this is the
stuff that's after your book when we
talk about the refugees and some of the
economic problems in Europe and this you
know dealing with radical Islam it was
going on while you were writing the book
obviously but it seems it seems to me we
have like five things right now that are
all working at the same time then you
toss in social media you toss in you
know that we see
goes from everywhere now we see we can
see beheading x' we can see bombing you
know so you can see you can see
religious violence and you can see state
violence all the time that we really
have all of this happening at once and
it's leading to a very strange place
yeah I mean I think one thing Dave we
can say with certainty that whoever it
was Francis Fukuyama who said off the
falls and full the Berlin walls at the
end of history
history's over boring was a stupid thing
to say and uh and you can't you can't
look let me go back to the point I made
you right at the start that the
weirdness and hypocrisy and the awful
betrayal of people you get on people who
call themselves a left comes where they
don't have a socialist alternative you
they don't have the Soviet Union Falls
socialism collapses across the world no
one believes in it anymore and then
that's fine for a while if I may
generalize in a very glib way that was
fine for a while because capitalism
we'll call it what you will seem to be a
great success story mm-hmm seem to work
that's why Francis Fukuyama was up
session idiot when he said history was
over well ever since the crash of 2008 -
system of liberal capitalism has failed
and that's why you've got this feeling
of you know perfect storm too many
things coming us as at once is it is not
entirely yep there's a wonderful phrase
by the Italian socialist Antonio Gramsci
the oldest dead the new cannot be born
in that interregnum many strange strange
forms will appear it seems like that we
don't know what comes next we're not
sure of what we've got but not sure it
works anymore not sure it works oh yeah
opening this middle-class American box
in your program hello there pay isn't
going up the super rich are getting
richer the American Dream doesn't seem
to quite work anymore even with it with
Obama listen not quite clear where the
alternatives to that aren't so you get
these strains of Oren's
free kiss forms which when I wrote that
book yeah as I said him just kept saying
for Nick Nick
that's jest though suggest on the
fringes well now it's on the main screen
going to that point what about some of
the tactics these guys use and I want to
talk a little bit about Chomsky but
first we can talk just sort of in the
more broader sense when I've seen the
way these guys debate the way they treat
topics and you know again everyone's
racist and all that they don't seem to
mind if they get caught in lies they
love just throwing out the bomb and then
we let it spreads like wildfire on
social media and you know there's that
famous saying you know it takes one
second to lie but it takes you know a
lifetime to get it back or whatever it
is and it seems that a series of these
guys they love this and I don't know I
look again I'm not on the right so I
can't write I don't like the right I've
never been part of the right
so I police them differently but I don't
want to see this from my guys so what do
you think about just the tactics that
they're using them so before any further
day one question to you
yeah plain speaking open heart sure easy
it doesn't right behave any better than
that know me people look they don't look
I'm look I'm dealing in America with
Trump right the second with over the top
bomb Basset II so and again this is why
look I'm a guilty liberal in that sense
that sometimes I feel bad I spent so
much time on the guys on my side and
then I'm afraid you know people ask me
all the time am i afraid that ultimately
this will strengthen the right but I but
to me it's like if we don't stand up now
well then the game is over we just hand
it to the right which is what's
happening I think with Trump yeah uh
well um there is a long tradition of
lying
left you know if you go back to to
Stalin you know he he dot gullible
people to believe in so trials where
people confess the crock impossible
crimes that weren't committed so there
is that um I'm I'm less interested
unless concerned about left and right
than this here's something that happens
when with new media you know have stays
here Fox News I think is a pretty bad
thing
I think his main audience seems to be
little girl this look is reasonable
Tyrael too right but yeah it's a bad day
you've got nothing to do you got no
ideas I know I'll turn on fox news it
you've now got States Russia and Iran
most notably producing propagate and the
channels that are dedicated to pushing
half-truths conspiracy theories lies you
know a jet shot down over Ukraine
there's television channels in English
who are pumping stuff out so you look
whereas wants if you're on the left in
America you just have to go on all about
something Nixon was putting out or
something in the walls began leaving
something on Fox News you and if you're
on the right in America you can play
about New York Times you know
deliberately covering something up now
you suddenly got whole states with their
secret services their foreign offices
their propaganda arms behind them
pumping material into the West which is
instantly taken up by both the far left
and the far right he's it's very
difficult to certainly in Britain as I
say things have gone much much further
than they have in America it's very very
difficult to tell the part the people
who support Putin for instance and
Russia today you know you've got marine
lepen doing it who is the lead for
French far-right party you got George
Galloway who's his strange combination
or the less dismiss and listen Britain
you don't I mean and so you've got a
kind of merger of the extremes against
liberal democracy and they're both
equally key on Putin they're both
equally sympathetic to Iran they what
matters to the most is is building
conspiratorial narrative so in a lot of
ways we really could blame sort of
mainstream media for this craziness
right because it seems to me that for a
long time
mainstream media which had no
competition before the digital age they
did such a poor job that then they
handed everything over to the digital
side and I think for a while the online
media
for the first few years of it I think
they did do a really nice job in
breaking stories and getting out
information yeah then wouldn't that you
wouldn't get otherwise and now it seems
like the gloves are off and now it's
anything's true nobody knows who to
trust
yeah um yeah there's a little proof now
I do accept some kind of binary division
between new media and old me too it's
good journalist and that's about just
like but it's prom day if you are me at
the Guardian we observer or on the LA
time to you you don't report on the LA
Times and you say when you've done a
terrible job of your allowing all these
cranks these fruitcakes these flim-flam
merchants from all over the world to
walk all over you the man or woman in
the LA Times has looked at our business
models collapse you know we're trying to
start bureaus in in Peking in Beijing in
Tehran yeah give me a break
yeah we can bet we can bet we can barely
get a reporter appeal at the road San
Francisco and the business model for if
you like serious current aseptically
serious foreign journalism is getting
hard and have sustained although I'm
sure the LA Times and newspapers and
across America are to my knowledge from
having met met the man will work on them
are really dedicated to try and keep it
going but yeah in the end the lack of
money talks you know money talks that
the silence that comes from the lack of
money is a silence which guess which
guess closes debate so the gap is just
being filled and what worries me is is
not people talking rubbish or people
talking drivel history they all have is
where are you going to get the reliable
reports on what is happening in Peking
well Beijing where are you going to get
the reliable reports on how Kuching is
manipulating a European opinion that's
getting hard and hot - okay well as
someone that I consider an expert in
this space how do you decide who to
trust I I really don't know anymore I
you know I follow a lot of different
organizations right left middle you know
as
reputable and some off the deep end and
I try to pilfer out some knowledge and
and some truth and I try not to only
follow things that reinforce my beliefs
which is another huge problem in social
media has given us but how do you decide
who to trust
well I mean David we've only got accused
of being horribly old-fashioned stuff
but I mean there are still organization
so I trust you know I still trust not
score New York Times News pages yeah
unless it's because I know there's a
very very strong editing process there
and it's opinion pages are separate and
what has you know that may changes as
the business model journalism goes down
but I still don't look they had an op-ed
on the front page for the first time in
95 years just now described how
disgraceful
hey let's go around this wheels go round
have a demo sorry we don't want your
bloody opinions we also say give us some
news I'd read a paper that had that on
the on the front all right so let's back
up for a second let's talk for a few
minutes about Noam Chomsky because you
talk about him a bit in the book it's
not a tremendous amount but you but I
have a friend who's on what I consider
in this regressive group and a lot of
times we'll be debating back and forth
about this stuff and I'll be giving him
as much historical knowledge as I have
and as much factual knowledge as I have
and then he'll sort of always end
everything by saying well I don't really
know about that but I read some Chomsky
and I'm just kind of giving it back to
you and I think you sort of hit on that
also in the book that there there's just
this belief in this guy that maybe isn't
fully warranted or he's been he's been
very good at waving off the things that
don't quite agree with his worldview
yeah is he seems to sing for two reasons
I mean born you know without I mean he's
an old guy I don't come on be envious
shutting down by me he's adopted some
pretty disgraceful positions denying
masochist above Bosnian Muslims and
going along people who it's 1990s and
going along time
I never admitting is wrong and building
this very tall skis racing it's very
poor writing self stance of English but
it builds is very dense where the light
your friend wants you're in you're like
a fly forcing the web
very hard to get out so that's but
that's that's kind of fishing you say
fiscally in America you fish tide I know
what this thing is but I don't know yeah
you say look this man this is this is
all from the point of view it sort of
made up and actually figure out what
he's doing it's quite disgraceful but
here's why I for Chomsky was worth
devoting chapter two is this what kind
of you are young radical an American
campus and you get your Chomsky you read
all these books and you think well what
kind of society are you aiming for there
is no social vision there's nothing that
the progressives and socialists who run
for American history from the 1880s
would recognize they'll just say what's
this all just saying America's [ __ ] you
give me major [ __ ] America would
probably have never happened the pilgrim
files we probably have turned around the
Plymouth Rock and gone back to England
yeah the whole thing is this a stir
everything he does is right thing is a
lie and you think well that's a
ridiculous world fish
funnily enough here's the thing it's
really easy to buy and yeah because you
don't have to commit to anything you
know if you do aggressive left and so I
really like that phrase well let's take
an aggressive way yeah Big Sean skin
left the post-socialist left on the one
hand it has very very little to say
positive on your hand that's that's kind
of easy for everyone to sign up to you
just have to think that Washington is a
pile of [ __ ] well you know I mean
Washington DC is a pile of [ __ ] well
that's sure as you can up yeah doctor
that the State Department doesn't know
what it's doing
yeah fine the CIA is wicked and so
instead of having a left wing you had to
make really positive commitments for you
know 40 years ago I could have come on
your program and said I'm a socialist
right I'm a socialist and your audience
- hello I need Karen Jesus socialist
that sounds good we'll go along with him
he says and I said I want massively high
taxes or I want to nationalize this and
that and people who would have been
agree with single back off and say hell
I don't want anything to do this yeah
this guy is threatening my living
standards now you just have to say that
everything you reads ally your
governments evil and this is it and so
something that's actually because they
are making so few positive policy
commitments as Chomsky does it's
suddenly very easy to go along with him
you know I go to the homes of people
here in London which is a very expensive
city I go into the richest people I know
and their books by Noam Chomsky on on
the pop yeah on the open air shelves and
that's because suddenly enough for all
suppose radicalism that kind of left and
without a positive program of just the
critique is no threat to them it's no
threat to the world is no threat to
empower is no threat to the bankers on
Wall Street you know it's something lots
of people when they're quite justifiably
often pissed off the government or
because you know that they they've got a
conspiracy theory mind or because they
will look friendly everyone can sign up
to that
genuine left-wing program is hard again
you and left we program makes friends
and enemies but this kind of pseudo
leftist regressive left it's terribly
easy to believe even too easy I think
for any successful political movement
you know it's interesting because I was
really embedded in it for a couple years
and I guess I hadn't pieced this all
together what you're talking about but
right now but part of my frustration was
that we never talked about solutions we
always could talk about problems right
it was always you know the American
industrial complex and and bombing and
race and whatever but there were never
solutions so that that does get to what
you're saying that it's sort of big as
soon as you offer solution you're gonna
piss some people off yeah because it
solution me and you have to make a
commitment and as soon as you make a
commitment the people can say look days
Rubin believes in this once is wrong it
is very easy to just say it's all
conspiracy it's all stick yeah that way
you don't expose yourself you're not
making you're not making a positive
program and sticking your neck out there
I want you to see who shoots you down
so speaking of conspiracy theories one
of the through lines throughout the book
and then you do devote a chapter to it
in completion is that in all of these
movement
it's somehow blaming the Jews always it
always comes around to blaming the Jews
now the language has changed now it's
blaming Zionists or blame get it right
David no sense to use any more signs
right now it's right it's not it's not
politically correct to say Jews so you
just say Zionists or you say Israel or
whatever it is but you really did lay
out an interesting piece in almost every
example throughout time that they were
always black but on both sides the
capitalists would say the Jews are
socialists the Socialists would say Jews
are capitalists and every other which
way what what do you think that is about
I think you probably just explained it
with this conspiratorial thing and the
other right yeah well look here's the
problem if you genuinely think your
State Department's your CIA your
president for all all their many many
faults and I'm sure their lesion and but
if you genuinely think that they for
instance secretly blew up the twin
towers and then they'll kinda take the
blame they invented a way to go into a
boy and rock a bomber is you've lice the
writers not just left you know a barber
isn't a real American he's a secret
Muslim Kenyan
you know if you can you believe it all
that you have to believe in
extraordinary view of the world where a
handful of people can fool the entire
populations the sheeple well once you
think about who are those handful of
people historically you know well you
start down that road you end up in the
gute what I found shocking being called
caring that is is gonna add to this yeah
and I think some of the you know your
liberal American views will find it
shocking because I say width I had use
ahead of you
when it comes in hit CERN is this I help
me I never expected to find out you
senators on there perhaps I was being
naive and but it is quite extraordinary
the extent of it and it's quite
extraordinary how its tolerated now it
isn't cool down now so do you think some
of that when I hear people say that and
first
real quick we should mention so you just
mention your last name Cohen you're
actually not Jewish though you know who
are you I know Matt might not my family
abandon their religion for reasons of
Marxist so you know I'm I'm I'm from a
next communist family of about 1903 Jews
wouldn't have been stupid but yeah yeah
cool Cohen Dave it's not yeah right so
will people to think you're accused and
also you're curious but here's the
problem if you look at energy services
anti-semitism has virtually nothing to
do with genes anti-semitism became in
the late 19th century the early 20th
century and the czars and Nazis it is a
way of fighting progress it was a way of
saying look you democracy human rights
women's rights yeah all these you
shouldn't believe in them they're all
fakes they're all fraud says area
they're all behind them is a pipe master
pulling the strings and a puppet master
with the cute so yeah you would have
thought there's a left that believes in
democracy and human rights will be for
its own sake as much as anything else
only on alert the whole time for the
dangers of entities journalism but
actually you know going back to Chomsky
own believes the Boxee they believe
human rights is all they believe it's
all lie so that's one reason why they
end up there or not Chomsky himself but
that's why I'm using people are people
end up there and they don't understand
what goes with it they don't look at
organizations like Hezbollah or Iran or
and say homeless Eck okay they're
anti-semitic but that's just because of
Israel and then they don't have a home
say look away they she'd women look at
where they treat homosexuals look at the
way that they dismiss human rights the
way this miss democracy then goes and
anti-semitism actually goes along with
that and once you accept anti-semitism
you have to not just throw out
anti-racist but you have to wrap all
your progressive principles because
historically anti-semitism has always
been used by ultra yatra movements who
again the left should be against right
so this I always say when it comes to
this and I was just in Israel last week
and at the top of the show when I when I
did my my piece I was saying how I saw
coexistence
I was in Jerusalem you know I ate
falafel in the Arab quarter I saw
Israeli policemen helping Muslim women
move a box I saw ultra-orthodox Jews
well I mean that doesn't happen anywhere
in the Mideast
except for Israel and of course not to
say everything's perfect there and
there's all sorts of political problems
and religious problems and all that but
that does but the only place that is any
progressive values in the Middle East is
Israel and they well yeah yeah yeah but
I mean look you shouldn't engage in oh
what about three June and it's a lot
more power to invest there's quite a lot
what about three on the right you know
you say someone says well Anna's
problems on the West Bank there's
problems in Gaza you say what about
Syria which actually is quite a good
whatabout right yeah
then we say pelvis but when you think
about it and but you know you can say
that doesn't mean the Palestinians
should have their own state that doesn't
mean Oh horrendous problems with Israeli
right and you shouldn't some romance the
sighs Israel yeah at all and but but
yeah but here's the thing is the problem
the problem is is this is one of the
great reasons for I would say the
liberal liberal difficulty in
understanding radical Islam is there's
very good liberal impulse that assumes
the world is rational you know that
assumes that if there is this terrible
terroristic movement that will blur the
twin towers that would here we knew if
they had chemical weapons or nuclear
weapons they could be used against
civilians they would then must be a root
cause for it you know
there must be some rational explanation
that we can satisfy that we can
procreate these evil gods and they can't
just be that angry again stuff is not
partly our fault
yeah I saw I saw a lot of that actually
right after the Paris attacks because I
saw immediately my friends on the Left
saying American foreign policy American
foreign policy even though two days
later you know Boko Haram killed
hundred forty people and obviously that
has nothing to do with the marinara
policy but but there's this
rationalization even though at the same
time the people who did the Paris
attacks were saying this is for
religious purposes yeah but your friends
on the left your souls go into history
of narcissism with history of communism
yes there are rational reasons that you
can blame you know you could say if if
yeah bombs go off like Charlie Hebdo
office in Paris your friends left said
oh it's their fault they film things
cartoons of Muhammad yeah people are
slaughtered acts at the very supermarket
in Paris the Hydra Castro super mob oh
is their fault because of Israel because
Israel is occupying the West Bank it's
okay you kill the satirist that's okay
you kill the Jews that's a click people
are slaughters add to football stating
start the parents people are slaughtered
our rock concert people are sort of the
Cambodian restaurant on the Parisian
Bulevar well that's kind of their fault
because well we're not quite sure
American foreign policy making friends
foreign policy now these are sort of
rational explanations and there's a bit
of truth in them the problem is every
step you take seems rational and liberal
but every step you take takes you away
from rationality and liberalism and you
end up like the very murderous you're
trying to explain because you accept the
whole ideology but you don't understand
it you don't understand it there are not
people who are sitting there saying well
we've got a rational grievance like
someone about to file a claim it's a
county court they have a utopian
totalitarian ideology you know and
having lived through the 20th century
all a last bit of the 20th century 20
central you choking ideology still
millions and millions of people we still
don't understand that someone like
Islamic state says we think we can
create heaven on earth we think we can
create a caliphate that will govern the
whole earth and this will be paradox and
to do that what what's it matter with 1
billion 2 million 10 million people are
killed they don't they think they're
explained they don't
stand anything yeah so that actually is
the ultimate irony because on one hand
you're saying well look if we took
everything if we did whatever it is they
want us to do right we took all our
troops out of here we stopped bombing
here whatever then suddenly they they'd
like us more but that's not what they're
saying so it really is it's it's the
most ironic well what they want you to
do Davis become then yes to anybody if
you learn and so here you go I mean your
friends in California I'm probably yeah
I've met though I'm sure they're lovely
people so some of them do dark um but
I'm sure they they think themselves as
anti-sexist anti-racist uh and you have
a phobic I'm sure they're fine on trans
issues you know I bet some of them don't
even meet deep meet but they will then
through thinking they're being logical
end up defending the most sexist racist
homophobic a liberal movements on earth
and do so in there is another point made
by me is point they were very brilliant
French philosopher do so in a very
narcissistic way you know it's all our
fault
we are the center of the world you know
if something terrible happens it must be
down to us not that people in the rest
the world have their own agency not
people in the rest of welcome just as
wicked or stupid as we can they are
infants they are children who are goaded
by us it's all down to what we do we are
still here the narcissist the ego the
people the people of the central it all
yeah I think when I had Douglas Murray
on he Illustrated a point I said look
the world could go to hell in a
handbasket and it'll have nothing to do
with America you know there's you just
can't it's just child its childlike
thinking uh alright so increase
incidentally treats Muslim populations
as children you know if you infantile
autism yeah I mean says it says we're
adults where we are these white Western
Europeans yeah we can handle satire we
can handle our leaders and gods and
bishops and clerics locked by God you
can't
Muslims like toddlers here like Vine
little delinquent children you said in
the cartoon they dead why they start
blowing the place up
yeah ironically that's what george w
bush called the soft bigotry of low
expectations which I keep crediting Bill
Maher with but apparently it was george
w bush which is well mind-blowing
that is a very very good for face and
it's true actually it's worse than soft
bigotry it does keep people down because
looked muslim men and women watching
your program in california doesn't
really help that when they're going out
looking for a job or you're looking to
get on in life or what you're decreasing
respect want to be treated equals if
liberals are saying oh well you know
very very funny people these people you
have to be very careful what you say in
france from one cartoon they'll blow the
top my EP a-- yeah it doesn't help them
doesn't help them be full citizens to be
treated in a totally different way from
everyone else yeah absolutely all right
so i have one more for you i could do
this for five hours with you so you left
it you'll have to come on again um
pretty night here in England you know
yeah but I want I want to get you I want
you to have your tea go to bed so I'll
end with this look you wrote what's left
in 2007 that was eight years ago so
let's fast forward eight years from now
it's 2023 give it give me a little hope
if you can find some hope but if you
can't then give me where you think we're
going to be at eight years from now well
that was actually funny enough that book
was quite hopeful and I still visit
myself women I wrote that less said if
there's hope it will rely on liberals
intellectuals feminists with in in the
Muslim world within Muslim communities
in the West taking on their premise I
just hope that the shade which is
descended on Western liberalism well
it's one of those shameful periods of
history that when those liberals and
those Democrats and those feminists take
on their extremist [ __ ] Western
liberals to the once do what they're
meant to do and support them instead of
supporting their enemies so making
excuses for their enemies yeah for once
lived
principals always I'll just give up give
up shut up say actually we're not really
liberals at all we just want to go to
the beach
have a beer don't care we don't really
care about other people but either give
up or show some solidarity yeah well I
love that and I do like a well-placed
[ __ ] so that was that was really nice
too you guys can pick up either of
Nick's books wherever books are sold or
you can download an e-book however you
do that I did it so you can probably
figure it out Nick it was really it was
an absolute pleasure I hope we can do
this in LA in in person next time and I
thank you guys for watching I will do it
again next week
you